so right now it's looking like Marvel
Studios might only be releasing one
movie in 20124 now of course we hope
that is not the case we hope things get
back on track soon with the MCU and
their release schedules but even if they
do get back on track relatively soon it
looks like we might only have even at
that point only two movies come out in
2024 what's up everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder where we keep you
updated on the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I'm Warren Thompson and today we have
some news about some phase five projects
which of course if they are delayed like
they're being reported to be we also
inadvertently direct Marvel's Phase 6
schedule and right now movies like
Deadpool 3 Spider-Man beyond the
spiderverse and the Thunderbolts have
released dates attached to them that
this brand new report States as not real
and sadly we anticipated this we
realized that due to the strikes there
were probably going to be some more
delays but we didn't think we would be
left with one or two movies for 2024
however there is good news that comes
with this which of course we'll break
down in this video and reminder only a
few days left in our giveaway if you
want a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items all you have to do is subscribe
and leave a comment down below we pick
one random winner from one random video
at the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item now of course we
are still in the middle of strikes right
now luckily and fortunately for
everybody the rer strike is over un
fortunately it did cause some damage as
far as release dates are concerned with
movies and shows and the actor strike is
still continuing also affecting release
dates and this report is coming from
deadline today with the title wga and
amtp Deals impact on film uptick and
future writers jobs Market but actors
scheduling conflicts down the road the
article basically talks about how the
strikes have affected the studios and
talks about how if the actor strikes in
soon when exactly the studios will kind
of pick everything back up again they
state in the article there's optimism
that the majority of network dramas and
comedies will be able to launch in the
new year thanks to news of a pending
deal last night should the SAG after a
strike end in the near future which is
the actor strike they say most feature
Productions are eyeing a 2024 start or
restart date so this is basically
stating that even if the actor strikes
do ens soon most studios are eyeing 2024
to pick things up again the New Year
fortunately for us that's only a few
months away but then the article said
this about Marvel they said as expected
due to the ongoing sag after strike the
2024 theatrical release schedule remains
in great flux one Motion Picture
marketing Source over the weekend
characterized next year's release
calendar as not real meaning it remains
in question whether movies which haven't
completed production I.E Marvel Studios
Disney's Deadpool 3 and Mission
Impossible 8 and Spider-Man beyond the
spider version the latter which requires
plenty of voiceover work even meet their
release dates basically they're stating
that these movies that have been
scheduled for 2024 that have not been
completed yet and production was shut
down recently this year due to the
strikes they're basically saying that
any releas dates for those type of films
are not real and are most likely going
to be pushed back sadly this is most
likely very true for Deadpool 3 the film
is most likely going to be delayed
however we keep our fingers crossed that
it won't be delayed until 2025 we hope
it's delayed only a few months because
the strikes have only gone on for a few
months now however why it remains in
flux is the oor strikes aren't done yet
hopefully it does end soon and plenty of
outlets are reporting that the studios
are going to meet with sag Afra next
week so fingers crossed for that and
hopefully they get a deal done they were
able to work out one with the wga so
hopefully they can work out one with sag
after I'm assuming they will the only
question is how long is that going to
take because that will ultimately
determine how long long some of these
projects are delayed for now the one
movie I said was locked in the one movie
we could get in 2024 is Captain America
Brave New World that is currently
scheduled for July 26th of 2024 and that
one should be locked in because
production was done they should have
everything they need to stick to that
release date so that's our worst case
scenario we only get Captain America
Brave New World now unfortunately the
Thunderbolts are definitely going to be
pushed back their production has been on
hold and they were already scheduled for
the very end of 2024 for December 20th
of 2024 so if that movie is even
affected in the slightest which we know
it was we know production for that was
on hold as well and currently still is
that's definitely going to 2025 so we're
holding out our hope that Deadpool isn't
delayed till 2025 and Marvel Studios
will definitely try to make it happen in
2024 but sadly it looks like our best
case scenario right now is two Marvel
films in 2024 however like I mentioned
there is some good news there are
currently a a lot of Disney Plus shows
planned for 2024 now we know Marvel
Studios was kind of changing their plan
Disney as a whole was kind of changing
their plan with their Disney Plus shows
the frequency which they released them
and how many they made but fortunately
for us right now there are quite a bit
of Disney Plus shows scheduled for 2024
that hopefully don't get delayed but
there's so many that even if some do get
delayed we'll still have plenty of
content in 2024 so here's how 2024 is
looking for Marvel and I'll even throw
in the Sony Marvel projects as well now
first I'll go ahead and throw this in
there Spider-Man beyond the spiderverse
has simply been taken off the schedule
it currently does not have a release
date although it is still speculated it
could possibly happen in 2024 however
given the recent article by deadline
that doesn't seem likely however there
is a chance it could happen at the end
of 2024 but besides that we have echko
season 1 which is going to release all
at once all episodes all at once then in
February of 2024 we have Madam Webb and
this is supposed to be a pretty
important movie for Sony in the comics
Madame web has the ability to travel the
Multiverse so we're thinking that the
live action spiderverse on the Sony side
is going to be established in this movie
so look out for that one then we have
X-Men 97 the Animated Series Deadpool 3
if it remains true but we know it's
probably going to be moved from its May
3rd release date but then Captain
America Brave New World and then we have
Craven the Hunter coming August 30th it
was originally supposed to come out in
2023 but it was delayed due to the but
then we have Agatha the darkhold Diaries
season 1 that is coming fall 2024 we
have the Thunderbolts which again
probably won't make it but scheduled for
2024 is also Spider-Man freshman year
and Marvel Zombies so there are five
Marvel Studios Disney Plus shows
scheduled for 2024 and a lot of them
have already been worked on some of them
have wrapped already with production so
we assume that not all of them are going
to be delayed let's say two get delayed
then we still have three Disney plus
project projects three Disney plus
projects from Marvel Studios hopefully
combined with two MCU movies that's a
good amount of content that's kind of
what we're used to at this point plus
not to mention there is what if season 2
that is supposed to start Christmas time
of 2023 so that'll bleed over into 2024
as well that plus Sony's Madam web and
Craven the hunter will still have quite
a bit from Marvel and let's just keep
our fingers crossed that Deadpool 3
doesn't get kicked back to 2025 the good
news is Marvel Studios definitely does
not want this they want want two movies
at least released in 2024 so they'll
most likely just take Deadpool move it
from May to perhaps December hopefully
sooner than that hopefully we don't have
to wait that long and the writer strike
is now over and both sides are eager to
tackle the actor strike next so
hopefully that'll be over within the
next few weeks as well and things will
pick back up again and these projects
could only be delayed by 3 to four to 5
months not years but currently as we
stand that is the possibility for 2024
go ahead and let us know your thoughts
about the 20 24 slate down below what
project are you most excited for let us
know in the comments also don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all things Marvel and to
enter our giveaway you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof